[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor kevin mcguire and the
telegraph's assistant comment editor
olivia artley both of them with us from
now until just before midnight welcome
to both of you
so let's see the front pages then and
starting with the financial times which
leads with the story dominating the news
tonight their headline more than 30
migrants drown in the worst disaster of
the channel surge
the metro asks why didn't france stop
them
here's the telegraph's front page which
declares 31 migrants die in channel
disaster
it is also the lead story for the
guardian which shows a mother helping
her children to the shore from a
different boat in dungeness
the eye describes today's victims as
having died in search of a better life
the delhi mirror reports on how the
lives of children are put at risk as
they cross the channel
and the sun caused today's events
shameful
well let's bring in then kevin mcguire
and olivia artley and
kevin for many of those with this sad
prediction that one day
you know this day would come this is a
very dangerous shipping lane and here we
have at least 31 dead
and now what did the politicians do
yeah i think they'll start blame game
there was that statement the call
between boris johnson and
emmanuel macron the french president
about how they will cooperate more and i
think they they probably will i think
that will now happen they will see the
severity of the threat but there's no no
doubt there's going to be a finger point
in both sides uh the mayor of calais uh
blaming uh cynical johnson
uh boris johnson saying how come these
these boats were allowed to be launched
and
people traffickers are literally getting
away with murder but it is absolutely so
agreement as you said it was a terrible
inevitability about this if those
crossings were continuing and uh off
dubs lord alf dubs he was a child
refugee himself he fled the nazis to
come to britain on the kinder transport
he said yes it's a tragedy but it's not
unforeseen
and then i think on but on both sides
it's yes it's been a political issue but
it's too often just been a slanging
match and 31 people have paid with their
lives that's men women children we we
call them migrants but they're you know
their moms dads brothers sisters
fathers mothers uh you know they are
real people flesh and blood humans like
us yes and a conversation tonight uh
olivia between the the french president
and uh boris johnson the uk prime
minister they agreed uh the readout from
downing street says on the urgency of
stepping up joint efforts to prevent
these deadly crossings and to do
everything possible to stop the gangs
responsible for putting people's lives
at risk and certainly the focus from
downing street has always been on this
business model of the people smugglers
and on the fact that the french need to
clamp down on the coastline but is it
time for a major rethink uh now
for example the suggestion by many that
actually the processing of these asylum
claims needs to be done in france in
order to negate the need for anybody to
make the crossing
i think i think yes i think there
definitely is an argument for that i
think that both macron and boris johnson
have have a pretty good point tonight um
as you say macron's macron's saying that
that that the british aren't doing
enough aid to
we allow immigrants to work illegally
it's far too easy for them to get into
the black market market there's a very
big incentive for them to come over here
um it's it we don't really deport
migrants when they do arrive here so so
of course they're going to come here um
and we're not really doing enough to
stop that but but as as boris johnson
says the french authorities aren't doing
nearly enough to stop these evil people
smuggling gangs um who are who are just
trying to take money out of the pockets
of some of the most desperate people in
the world and are killing them in the
process he's right to say that it's
close to murder the problem is that as
we said as kevin said it's it is a
slanging match and up until now there
have been surprisingly few tragedies
this year actually we've had remarkably
good weather and and
luckily really just as a result of luck
um very few people have died making
these crossings so both macron and
johnson have been kind of ramping up the
rhetoric attacking each other and
actually they know that that's pretty
politically expedient for them the
english love around with french the
french love around with the english um
boris and matt corn are both
worried for different reasons about
their leadership and and in a way it it
it helps them to sort of to to poor
petrol on on the on the sort of row with
each other um and they just sort of
thought well that answer would be that
many tragedies at the moment you know i
think in the back of their heads they
thought it seems to be
it's not it's not a disaster yet and now
it has become a disaster and and as
everyone's saying tonight it was all too
predictable yes and kevin we see a
political divide don't we in this you
know politically divisive story in the
newspapers we saw the metro there why
didn't france stop them paragraph from
the telegraph with boris johnson saying
the government which is providing 54
million pounds to france for extra
policing would increase its support
suggesting he backed joint patrols on
french beaches to intercept migrants
before they sail whereas the guardian uh
saying that charities are now urging the
uk government to to save lives by
opening up safe routes for asylum
seekers so you know this is divisive and
and is there you know a happy medium
somewhere through this
yes we can discover it i think why
didn't the french stop them as a
perfectly legitimate question but it is
not the only
question and as the guardian raise if
you choke off all legal routes into the
uk
then people who are desperate will try
and find other ways that's when they
become prey to the people smugglers now
having legal routes allowing asylum
claims to be processed in france
wouldn't uh end the cross-channel uh uh
trade completely but it would actually
reduce it and you would give people a
hope elsewhere because they are
illegally entitled as refugees and
asylum seekers to go to the country
that's their destination now when we
were members of the european union you
had the so-called dublin convention
which was an arrangement that uh
samsung's migrants were supposed to stay
at their first uh the first safe country
they reached that doesn't apply now
we're out the european union but
international or the un convention is
you can go where where you want and in
some ways people want to come to britain
and they want to start as the eye put it
a a better life they want to work they
want to contribute uh they want they
want to prosper is a compliment to
britain uh some of it is they they have
relatives here already the languages and
attraction um the ability to work is an
attraction too and if we try to make it
fort was britain and we just try to keep
everybody out in a world that we know
is to stabilize with wars with poverty
with famine with climate change with
persecution some of the countries people
are coming from uh for instance syria
and iraq are armed forces have been
involved there so we know uh that there
is trouble in those regions they want
they want to come and it's it's
understandable and we need somehow to
play our role because we get very very
few migrants and refugees compared to
most of the countries in the world
mainly they stay very locally
for instance syria there are far more
syrian refugees in lebanon in turkey and
in jordan there are then are certainly
in the uk
um but all these questions have have to
be asked and hopefully they can be asked
an answer in a kind of rational non
non-blaming way but i think i think we
will just descend into that and some
petty politics will come forward but
what happened today with 31 dead when
people like nigel farage was saying the
rnli was just a
taxi service picking up people in in in
the channel i don't know how he will
sleep at night now
after saying that because these people
they've gone in the i think it's in the
metro the french interior minister says
they'd set sail or they'd been put in
what was essentially a
paddling pool that's how he described it
he said it was like something you would
inflate in your in your
gardener
that's the desperation that they that
they have and we don't want people
drowning off the coast of the uk they
were the way they were in the
mediterranean as they were leaving
places uh countries such as libya and
certainly the the mirror that we saw
there as well olivia
showing as they put it vulnerable faces
six children about to cross the channel
in a different inflatable uh under the
noses of watching french cops as the
paper puts it but just quickly
politically you know how does this feed
into the brexit debate of uh you know
we're going to take control of our
borders the niger parish taxi service
idea pretty patel with the idea of naval
frigates you know
patrolling and everything how tough does
the government need to be seen to be on
this story and
what is their instinct to tell them to
do right now
well i mean it couldn't be a more
decisive issue you look at
twitter and immediately you know you
search channel crossings on twitter and
you see that it's divided in half
between people saying um this is the
fault of the french authorities is the
evil people smuggling gangs the solution
is to process migrants offshore to break
that link between coming to britain and
living and working in britain that's the
sort of right traditional conservative
argument and then you've got the the
left-wing argument which is the problem
is that these are all desperate asylum
seekers and they're not economic
migrants they are they are people who
desperately need our help and we we've
cut off all routes to safety and we
should open our borders and as allow
allow as many refugees as possible um
into the country uh i think you know
kevin kevin's right to say that say that
the world is becoming a more dangerous
place and we do have to sort of live up
to our international responsibilities
and i think the government will
recognize that um partly because it's a
cooperation very difficult with other
countries that government refuses to
sort of accept their international
responsibilities and i think it is it is
true and i think the government will
recognize that there are too few routes
to genuine for genuine asylum seekers
coming to the uk um there's so much
bureaucracy it takes such a long time to
get to britain and if you're really
really desperate you don't have that
sort of time
apologies we are running we are running
well over there's so much to say it's
certainly dominating the newspapers we
will turn our attention to other matters
after the break including ross johnson
making his first appearance at pmq since
his somewhat gaff laden speech earlier
this week
[Music]
with sky store premiere watch brand new
movies at home while they're in the
cinema troublesome
we thought he must be dead
i've come back to play
you don't know what this is
[Music]
no time to die available now in sky
store premiere
those players are actually disgraced
they should take responsibility we've
got to do that someone's got to go in
that dressing room and be a leader
there's no time for recriminations no
more room to hide a fallen giant can get
right back up again but it will require
true character because there will be no
mercy at the bridge
chelsea hosts the man united team with
everything to prove
watch live in this venue
we've got a bumper crop of deals at
morrisons like a british beef joint from
our butchers 5.99 per kilo
morrisons make good things happen
over half a million skybet customers use
deposit limits to help manage their
betting budget that's enough to fill 46
cops 160 lofts 19 valleys 22 deep deals
25 dens or 65 six steals that's a lot of
sports fans who know their limits all
good bookmakers have deposit limits so
whoever you bet with set an appropriate
one and enjoy the sport deposit limits
that's betting better
how can aerial pods help with climate
change wash colder and sea
now when we take on tough stains like
mud
and sweat
we can save energy
aerial pods work brilliantly on cold
to give you an outstanding clean
and if we all turn to wash colder we
could save as much co2 as taking up to
half a million cars off the uk roads
pod colder and reduced co2 always keep
away from children
on a great hair day i feel that little
bit stronger
my hair won't bring home the title but
feeling unbreakable sure can
because the power of hair isn't just how
it looks
it's how it makes you feel pantene grows
strong with biotin and bamboo for
stronger longer hair awaken your hair
and your power
try pantene lift and volume with biotin
and rose water get fuller thicker
looking hair pantene
[Music]
cases of anxiety and young adults
arising as experts warn of the effects
on well-being caused by the pandemic
[Music]
wow
[Music]
this night just us two well it reminded
me of how good our years together
[Music]
this is the moment i think about
whenever i think of us
find your moments that matter with piano
cruises
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now kevin mcguire
and olivia artley
there they are welcome back uh welcome
back to both of you so after what might
be described as a torrid week for the
prime minister he uh he faces the
commons how did it go kevin
yeah i think it's a turret three weeks
everything in the
kia starmer said is everything okay uh
prime minister which it causes what a tv
reporter said to the to boris johnson
after he made that uh peppa pig's ear of
uh speech on monday at the cbi and there
were more tory mps behind boris johnson
today but you could just see uh kirsten
has changed his approach i think it's
been a a combination of sleaze and the
self-inflicted own goal by johnson which
alienates somebody with mps but also the
fact that i just wonder he had to go and
isolate with covert key a star but he's
come back
fizzing with energy and and more
aggression i just wonder if he used that
time to have a good think and a reset
yeah or a nap who knows it's it's a busy
time isn't it um final quick story from
you olivia first noelle it always takes
me a while to get these gags in the
pages i have to say but anyway a festive
booze shortage
i know it sounds like a nightmare i
think that's a very good way to get uh
people to sign up to be an hgv driver
tell them they can't any booze at
christmas if they do
well that was brief anyway thank you
very much indeed okay
i'm just trying to read what sort of
shortage uh bucks fears i'm not sure
we'll have that anyway
and jyn may be in short supply there's
so many gene companies now that really
can't be an issue i don't think anyway
kevin olivia thank you both very much
indeed